all right Amanda
Amanda where are you from where'd you
grow up I am originally from Manhasset
Long Island
um I my parents and I moved from
Manhasset Long Island when I was three
years old and so I primarily grown up in
Chicago
tell me about your childhood
um like most childhoods you know it had
its sadnesses and disappointments but on
on whole I had a very nice childhood for
a decent childhood my mother was a
jungian psychoanalyst and a professor
um and my father was a professional
Advertiser and an oil painter so I spent
a really significant portion of my
childhood running around ad agencies and
making lots and lots and lots of art
yeah and schooling you went how far I um
so I thought that eight years ago I had
completed my my Graduate Studies at the
school of the Art Institute of Chicago
in print media lo and behold I was
trying to get a copy of my diploma just
very recently and only to discover that
I was short three credits so as of uh
yesterday actually I have I have now
completed those three credits so I have
now completed my graduate degree and I
hope to go further yeah what do you do
for work
um I'm unemployed at the moment
um I I am a caregiver so that's kind of
a job yeah that's what you've been doing
that's what I've been doing yeah for a
long time now and um and a lot of
antenatalist activism
so tell me what anti-natalism is sure so
anti-natalism uh put as simply as I
possibly can is the belief that it is
unethical to create new life now there
are many different types of antenatalism
there's many different types of
antenatalists there's a lot of different
motivations for anti-natalism there's a
lot of you know reasons why different
reasons why people might find themselves
to be some form of anti-natalist
antinatalism can apply to a great many
things and there's huge disagreements
among anti-natalists about all of those
things so most
um commonly it is the belief that it's
unethical to create new human lives but
this can also
apply to animal lives as well and it can
also apply to
um you know creatures that might become
sentient at some point like the
emergence of sentient machines there's a
whole form of anti-natalism called
anti-ai natalism so if those
um machines were essentially to gain
sentience that we would see that as
unethical and those were our lives worth
preventing and is your side of it
particularly focused on humans I'm I'm
what is called a sentiocentric
anti-natalist or a biocenter biocentric
anti or a reverse biocentric
antidatalist
um which means that I'm I'm for the
non-existence of of anything that has
the possibility of feeling
really yes
so so my anti so I didn't interrupt you
but yeah so my antidalism would apply to
not just humans but to animals to
sentient machines to anything that dogs
cats squirrels frogs
the whole the whole kitten caboodle they
should all go they should all go yeah in
the trees
well the trees are not you know they're
alive but they're not sentient so if
there's a possible you know there is
sort of a cut off a limb of a tree it
doesn't it doesn't make it scream so my
my concern is anything that has the
possibility of saying ouch
now there is also this sort of Specter
of evolution you know out there
um if uh you know if if Jeff Goldblum
was right in in uh in Jurassic Park you
know to philosopher didn't didn't say
that famous line you know life finds a
way if life finds a way and it manages
to become sentient you know if the trees
all of a sudden start winking at us and
start screaming then they would become
my concern but right now why is it that
you want
animals that feel to to be abolished
because I believe that the one of the
the greatest products of life is the the
the production of suffering there's all
of this incredible amount of suffering
that's basically one of the biggest
things that life produces life is uh on
the other hand there's also
suffering sometimes motivates us to
accomplish things that's absolutely true
so when once we're alive we need
suffering right like suffering builds
character we need to know when we're in
pain suffering has all of this can have
all of this value
um but the fact of the matter is when
before we exist
we certainly don't need it we're
certainly not in need of any of that
suffering you know when there's before
we exist there's nobody there just like
they're not in need of of all that
suffering that might be have some
utility to us while we're alive they
also are not in need of any of the good
stuff either there's all of you know all
the positives all the to have a good
life
that's we're not you know before we
exist we're not in need of any of that
and so to create a new being is to put
that potential uh sentient being at
Great risk at risk of a poor quality of
life we do that without consent now I
know what you're going to say it's
impossible to get consent of a
non-existent being but that's part of
the point that's the nature of consent
if you can't get consent then you don't
take those risks you don't impose that
harm
um yeah so this was to happen
the planet Earth would be just plants
and trees and yeah
insects well I mean insect sentience is
definitely there's a philosopher by the
name of uh of Brian tamasic who has done
a lot of work into the idea of insect
sentience and you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of I'm not entirely sure
where I fall on that but yeah if they
can be proven to experience negative to
have negative experiences then yeah
that's something to be concerned about
for sure I mean
yeah when you first told me that you're
interested in doing an interview and I
heard anti-natalies yeah I assumed it
was just humans because I I guess I
could see a strong argument for saying
the planet would be better off without
humans yes well uh well I mean the
damage we've done considering all the
damage were done yes so when we met uh
previously great things too of course
but we have we have surgery we're
starting to it's starting to flip and
then starting to wonder if we're better
off without us well I mean I I I think
that there's a there's a truth that it
it would I mean the planet certainly
would be better off without us I am uh
you know when we met downstairs and you
said those things to me I was like okay
so he so if he is an antenatalist if
Mark you are an anti-natalist you would
be an environmental antenatalist so that
would be sort of a form of conditional
antenatalism
um whereas maybe you wouldn't
necessarily be for extinction of human
lives but but definitely maybe a
lessening I don't know I I haven't
really thought it out yeah I'm not one
of those but yeah but uh I'm not an
anti-natalist but I yeah
um
I I just I just I just see how much
pollution certain countries are putting
out now you know the United States is
trying their best to help help things
but we have other countries
make me worse and that affects everyone
else yeah certainly yeah so I mean
certainly I I think that any amount that
we can alleviate the harm that humans do
is is excellent I mean I think so long
as life exists on the planet we should
try to make it as good as possible you
know antenatalism is not saying let's
just give up and let everything go to
Absolute hell like I'm not happy at all
about climate change or any of these
things that are going to cause massive
amounts of suffering they're not going
to cause Extinction they're going to
cause just massive amounts of suffering
and probably you know the civilization
collapse and all of that
I would prefer that human beings
decide collectively in a more benevolent
fashion to
and themselves in a in a much gentler
way and also to take responsibility for
the rest of Life on this planet now for
us that means just not procreating you
know there's no there's no need for any
violence there's no need for anything
nasty you know can we just collectively
decide we're not going to produce more
of ourselves and you know what kind of
interventionalism that needs to happen
for the rest of sentient life that gets
a little bit more complicated I did want
to say just real quickly though you know
everything that I'm saying as far as
animals sentient machines again you know
I need to make it perfectly clear not
all anti-natalists deal with that
spectrum of things at all I mean that
just happens to be uh part of my concern
but um like I said a lot of
antenatalists are concerned with
anthropocentric antenatalism that
applies to only humans so it gets pretty
complicated as far as
um where the where the Focus right so
there's yeah how long have you followed
this line of thought yeah so I started
in 2010 so when I was a kid I was really
obsessed with monsters still am love
love monsters and horror and all that
and I noticed that you know there were
little there were little Whispers of
sort of something something about life
something about procreation that a lot
of these stories were like seem to be
trying to tell me like there seemed to
be something very obvious about there
seemed to be a very obvious critique of
procreation in the story of Frankenstein
like maybe Dr Frankenstein should not
have created that monster like maybe
playing Prometheus wasn't such a great
idea you know maybe he just created this
being with you know unnecessarily you
know only to suffer and Die For No Good
Reason
um and so and also I was obsessed with
vampires and vampires you know by biting
each other they create more vampires and
that seemed to me to be sort of
appropriative act that seemed to be
making sort of a critique against
procreation so those ideas were in my
head you know for a long time but
nothing in our culture
um encourages this kind of thinking so I
figured well this is just one of the
things that's wrong with me
um and I'll just kind of ignore it and
that'll be that'll be fine
um but you know I've been making you
I've been making YouTube videos for
about 15 years so probably in
I don't know 2008 2009 or so you know I
was making videos of a completely
different kind I was a toy reviewer I
don't know if you know what Dragon Ball
is but I was obsessed with the toys
around Dragon Ball so I was making
Dragon Ball toy reviews and dressing up
as the characters and screaming into the
camera and I had a great time
um and then I started discovering you
know videos by people like in Mendham
and derived energy and metamorph
um
who were talking about antenatalism as
well as animal rights and topics like
the right to die and particularly
anti-natalism just it was like being hit
by lightning you know it was it was just
sort of the culmination of everything
that I'd been thinking and wanting to
find in the world you know since I was
such a little kid and so as an artist
um just as a person
again it was like being struck by
lightning it just it just inspired me to
such an incredibly huge degree
um that I've I've basically never
stopped and I've been producing uh
various forms of Art and activism around
the subject for yeah almost 14 years now
and I take it you don't have children no
no you've been in love before yes
certainly yeah I mean when you fall in
love with somebody and
progresses well you want to have sex
right you don't so so I don't think that
we really have a uh I think that the the
impetus to procreate is really
culturally built what we what we what we
want is to have sex we don't have an
instinct to have children we have a
cultural sort of mandate and a lot of
pressure put on us you know it's
something that so you're saying somehow
artificially we should uh protect from
and we have those two sections we have
those I mean a lot of those tools are
being taken away from us you know if I
get if I get raped tomorrow I I in in
this state I should be fine but in a lot
of places in America I don't have the
right to have an abortion but certainly
you know human beings have known how to
sever that tie between sex and
procreation for a long long time so
you're gonna have a hard time getting
everybody to get on board with this
absolutely there's no question about it
there's no question about it at all what
I believe
is that it's the right thing to advocate
for and uh I think that they're look
there is going to be for what purpose
now for the planet or for
eign
I think that living things are In Harm's
Way and we we as living things we
desperately need life to be good right
like we we create people because we have
all these Notions that they're going to
have happy lives that it's gonna they're
gonna do all of these things and you
know those are
often quite false Notions about the
reality of of those lives that we create
and I think that look there's all these
competing there will be a future of
humanity right and there's all these
competing philosophies and ideas about
what that future will look like like the
long-termists want to go on forever and
create as many people as possible and
let's get off the planet and spread our
misery anywhere we possibly can there's
a transhumanists who think that we're
gonna like you know um genetically and
and alter human beings so that we
experience gradients of bliss that have
you know hitherto unknown and we're
going to robot you know you know become
robots and it's going to be just
fantastic and
um and I I don't I don't I don't see
much hope in any of that I don't see
much
real you know movement towards that I
think I I don't think that I don't think
those things are going to happen but I
also think those things unfortunately
even though they look
really great on paper and people get
very excited about them and they see
them like hope and joy and
um positivity I think they
have the potential to cause a tremendous
amount of harm a tremendous amount of
suffering and so I think in my opinion
if we could just go
quietly into that good night we'll be
out of Harm's Way and I think that's
what really matters I think we've had a
real good run I think we've done lots of
interesting things it is going to go
away anyway unfortunately I mean our our
the extinction of all life on the planet
is just about an assured thing
but what that will look like in a
natural context you know if nature takes
us out
um
that's going to be pretty awful I mean
assuredly going to be pretty pretty
awful and you think there's lots of
suffering that's imminent if we don't do
something like this yes I do yeah I mean
for all the reasons you just mentioned I
think the signs that it's coming well I
think that the structure of the planet
is real we've done a lot of harm right
and we're we're these living sensitive
sentient creatures living on top of of
all of that and and yeah it's not gonna
you know it's not going to carry us
through to Glory Days forever I mean
it's we're kind of on borrowed time I
think
um so why don't we just get out of Dodge
while the getting's good you know
what's your biggest fear
um my biggest fear
my biggest fear honestly is that
this idea will not be listened to and
there will just be exponential amounts
of harm that we will invent new forms of
harm and suffering the human greed and
laziness is gonna yeah I mean we
undermine your yeah I mean we've it's
not to say I mean you know
I think there's a lot I mean there's a
lot that we can do to fix things on this
planet there's no question about that I
mean and I think we should do as much of
that as possible
um but I think that we haven't shown any
amount of uh success in combating things
like greed or avarice are are I think
there's all kinds of things that we
haven't come even begun to come close
um in in doing anything about if somehow
we could somehow eradicate human greed
and we all became very benevolent and
and worried about each other and worried
about the future and worried about the
planet
would then you still would you still
then be in entering I just don't see
much
I don't see much hope of that happening
I mean that's associated with the
transhumanists want to do I don't either
yeah but yeah well I I look I think if
we could if we could prove that if I
mean if we really showed signs of being
able to do that I would at least I would
no well I mean I I I think I think
Humanity would at least have an argument
that like maybe this is maybe this is
something you know uh
there would at least be an argument I
don't think I don't think we're making
much of an argument towards our
continuation at this point
yeah miracles happen
how many people are there that have this
belief so that's really hard to quantify
um there hasn't been a lot of
statistical work done on anti-natalism
like when I started in again in 2010
there We There were so few of us I mean
it was you know this really did sort of
the first antenatalist community of
sorts
um was really happened on YouTube you
know in 2010 like it was sort of you
know if you would all like sort of know
the history of YouTube you know before
that there were all these massive
debates on atheism that took place and
that was a huge part of what a what
YouTube was and
um the antenatalist community sort of
emerged a little bit out of that world
and it was sort of of that time was
religion tied into
well that's that's a great question so
yeah so I mean antenatalism is a is a
very ancient idea in I mean we would we
we would not call uh
ideas that are like that are like
anti-natalism from Antiquity they're not
exactly a one-to-one comparison with
what contemporary anti-natalism is but
yeah I mean there's been
proto-antenatalist ideas for uh you know
since you know the
uh
ancient Roman thinking the wisdom of
Salinas uh
um theogness I mean so many different
thinkers have kind of mentioned ideas
like this and one thing that has existed
is uh believe it or not a lot of
Christian anti-natalism like there were
all these sort of Christian antenatalist
sects that were Gnostic and you know
they didn't believe in eating animals
and they didn't believe in procreation
now a lot of that had to do with an
aversion to sex you know you know
because the well they're Christians you
know so there's a lot of aversion to sex
um that's not representative of what you
know contemporary antenatalism is but
that's sort of where you could say some
of it began I mean there are some
believe it or not Christian
antenatalists even today it's very rare
um there have you know there is
expressions of antenatalism in the
talmud there's uh I know not as much
about this but there are some you know
relationships with Buddhism and there's
a lot of
research I think that hasn't quite been
done yet
um on that on that field but but that
Christian antenatalism is something that
uh The Finnish antonyms philosopher
matihira and and I talk about in uh this
this new short book that we just wrote
um called antenatalism Extinction and
the end of procreative self-corruption
so yeah so there are some
some there is some uh
relation between early earlier you said
that you know humans have an urge to
have sex but not necessarily to
procreate yeah I think a lot of women
probably have a strong urge to have a
child well I I think I think a lot of
women are culturally mandated to have
that instinct I mean what do we you know
it's sort of the cliche example but like
what do we give little girls we give
them baby dolls you know mo you know I I
could probably say most women in most
cultures you know it's not a matter of
of when uh you're if you're going to
have a child it's when you know you're
sort of a a female's worth you know is
is in her procreative future I mean you
know you uh
boys become men and girls become
procreators
um and that's not the way it should be
or has to be by any stretch of the
imagination
um so I mean is that is that really
something that women have uh this
incredible desire to do is it something
that's that's mandated on most women to
have a desire to do their culture Yeah
by our culture exactly
um
there's and and I think there's a lot of
there's a lot that still needs to be
developed I mean sort of um you know
there's there's very few feminists in
antenatalism at this point there's some
um there's some feminist philosophers
that that are antenatalists like um
Patricia McCormack
um but and there's and but other
feminist philosophers that have
commented I don't like Christine overall
she believes that antenatalism is you
know bad for women whereas you know
somebody like Patricia McCormack would
totally disagree so I think there's a
there's a great deal
academically socially that needs to be
um further investigated
it's interesting because your philosophy
almost
is in in alignment with uh the doomers
that I've interviewed oh I mean in some
ways I mean the funny thing about the
doomers is that like why aren't they
telling people not to have kids if they
believe that all of this hell is about
to you guys should get together well
well there are definitely
there is definitely some uh doomers
within the antenatalist Spectrum and I I
think I mean those that I know and I've
spoken to often wonder exactly what I
just said like come on guys like if
you're if you believe that all this is
going to happen to humanity like why why
are we laying eggs in a broken Nest or
in a nest that's about to explode I mean
how how can you know
you know what real hope are we deriving
from continuing that you know if that's
what you believe the future is going to
be yeah
what do you what do you wish we all
understood better that we don't what do
you think we're not getting that it's
wrong to create need for no need so
before we exist we have no needs when we
exist we are inundated with needs and
most of those needs are just simply not
met during our lifetime I mean some of
you know some of us are luckier than
others to meet those needs there's
plenty of other people who are
desperately in need for those needs to
be filled we live in a world where you
know you can't gain without taking so in
order to satisfy your own need you're
sort of taking away uh
somebody else's needs satisfaction
um and that's unfortunately a big piece
of this thing that we're caught up in
um and it's it's just the on its face
completely unethical human greed sorry
again human greed human greed yeah there
you go yeah without human greed would be
a very peaceful loving
species well I mean I I think I think
that you know look there's all we're all
the products of DNA right like all every
every living thing is the product of DNA
and DNA didn't
I'm quoting my friend and Mendham here
as I have a couple of times in this
interview already I mean
DNA didn't go to school to be a good DNA
molecule to create happy beings you know
it didn't it didn't it its purpose is to
create beings that are best equipped to
compete with the environment you know to
create Gladiators who can uh battle it
out with each other so that there's a
winner you know that what nature is it's
about creating winners I mean I remember
you you you did this great interview I'm
sorry I don't remember who it was with
it was on somebody else's Channel and
you were walking down the streets of uh
of of skid row and and um you were
making I'm sorry yes yes thank you I'm
sorry about that yeah
um and you were making a comment about
how like yeah we can probably do a lot
to alleviate this
but like isn't this kind of what nature
is like it creates winners Illusions a
great comment and I think what what the
antenatalist would say from there is
like you're absolutely right Mark but
the fact that it creates winners and
losers is what we're really against here
the fact that it creates losers like
what is it about the winners that
justifies the creation of all of this
loss all this pain all of the all of
this misery like what can the winners
possibly be achieving that makes any of
this okay
and so it's it's a it's a bad game you
know we just keep playing this game I've
never created it screwed up
well yeah it's I mean this this this
piece of aberrant chemistry this DNA
molecule I mean you know that this is
this is this is what this is what
this is what keeps driving us but it
doesn't have to like we we human beings
are intelligent enough to go
you know we're not we really aren't as
Bound by our by our programming as we
really once were we have information
we've grown past that
um you know we've been told our entire
lives that there's nothing you can do
you know life is unfair and there's
nothing you can do about it there's just
there's you know this is what it is but
there's something really significant
that you can in fact do about it I mean
that the fact that the idea that you
can't do anything about how bad life is
and is an absolute lie you can enjoy
your life you're alive go do you know do
it don't do don't hurt anybody
um you know do as little harm as
possible but don't create more of it
don't keep saying yes to it well the
problem with your theory is there'll be
a dozen that actors who who don't comply
oh yeah sure and then you'll have an
even worse species on your hands well I
I look and I I my argument is not that
antenatalism is winning and I don't know
what possibility it has to win but like
I said I think that it is oh of the
possible Futures that humanity is facing
I do believe it is the one that will
create the least amount of harm and it
is the one that I would hope
um I think it is the most rational
um and I think that it is the one that I
hope that all I can do is make the
argument right
all I can do is really plead with
Humanity to not create more need for no
need
all right Amanda
thank you for sharing your interesting
thoughts my absolute pleasure mark thank
you for having me thank you very much
Amanda thank you